welcome to this video playing Ricki kids
Ricky kids from France it's a GM so
named Maxine y'all got a fling before I
played it before
okay we are going for Kings dammit some
someone recently requested that I should
play the Kings gambit again so why not
what exactly is this knight c6 after
Knight f3 mm well Bishop c4 is not the
problem because of g5 and maybe default
maybe default and not sure that this is
this should be a problem I don't I don't
really know a knight c6 but might be
might be a viable the viable move
alright so I probably should just take
it and recapture the pawn you can play
Queenie for now get to get the Queen's
off but nothing to fear down okay maybe
it's going for quick quick long castle
so maybe maybe maybe my development is
not not so great
okay yeah well I have I have King f2 if
everything else fails I can play king of
to the should see for now yeah I should
probably use this tempo
check check okay
I didn't didn't see that move at home
okay mmm
but if I go King g1 what exactly assist
move he can take f3 but I can just take
you form okay okay now this Bishop is
hanging out now that's a very strong
reply in fact
[Music]
yeah hi this is very good very good for
for black I didn't really have I didn't
really see the move okay so let's see if
I'm still able to fight King on G energy
one is not is not brilliantly placed
maybe my allows me to take it it's a bit
of a surprise taking it is probably
probably a bit cheeky what's black ID I
am Larry Bishop f4 to e3 something like
that I need to I need to get the room in
the game hard to hard to play without
the h1 rook
trying to prevent bishop inform hmm
yeah but is this is this really so great
[Music]
I think the position is is quite okay
unless I'm overlooking something really
something drastic but of course I've
been I've been very very slow
[Music]
try to defend using Bishop g4 and in
fact this is quite quite strong if he
moves the King there stood we should be
for trapping the Queen so I don't really
see what his move is
yeah this one okay and no I can I can
give the check 98 it's not helping okay
me to get the United to claim check so
it's got one pawn for the exchange
I could reform mmm damn it
yeah this would have would have just one
problem
Queens off should win or it should be
very close to winning he's got the two
pawns but with the active rook okay okay
let's try and do that check
[Music]
okay 50 seconds 50 seconds yeah two
points but at the moment they are not
not very mobile check
check check check
[Music]
girl Alfred I'm on 22nd so good girl all
wrong yeah I think I think I should
normally might should should continue
here but 20 seconds is not much really
and I didn't see a direct way to direct
way forward mm-hm I'm not sure if you if
you can really make make progress the
pounds are very strong maybe I could
have played better beforehand d5 is this
question okay I can go here actually now
taking at five it's not helping how to
how to improve him
maybe this one yeah this is probably
good it stops
pon pon at once the point wants to age 3
and also activates the rook this could
win computer is very optimistic about
what him hmm maybe maybe check check
check
also here ok three SS stronger yeah
probably
probably I need to stay here so that
after rook move I can actually go behind
the pawns or I have this idea
hmm it's maybe better on giving white
some winning chances complicated alright
thanks for watching